hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to today's broadcast on technological
innovations to speed protein
characterization by harsha gunawardena
phd
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and i
will be moderating today's event
before we begin i'd like to encourage
you to engage with us
you can submit as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation simply type them into the
ask a question box on the left and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right or use the
ask a question box on the left
please welcome dr gunawa dinner
good morning welcome everyone
first i would like to give my sincere
appreciation to agilent technologies for
giving me this opportunity to present at
today's webinar
in today's presentation i plan to share
a few important approaches we have
developed in our laboratories or in
collaboration with our partners to
improve protein characterization
workflows
as the title of my talk indicates we are
focusing on innovation to speed up
protein characterization
here is an outline that will guide you
to my talk
first i will give a brief introduction
to my group's role in large molecule
early development
next i will describe several different
approaches that are beneficial to
increasing biologics characterization
and how these can be used in a stage
appropriate manner throughout the
development of biologics
finally i will conclude my talk by
summarizing our findings and what we
hope to accomplish in the future
this figure represents the general
stages in large molecule early
development
once a target is declared during
pre-portfolio research candidates in the
range of 100 to 1000 molecules get
screened and filters through lead
generation and lead selection to less
than a few dozen molecules that enters
our department the cell and
developability sciences or cds for short
the cds group is responsible for the
selection of the cell line that goes
into late stage development and it's a
function that sits in between discovery
and development
the analytical function within cds uses
mass spectrometry to characterize
molecules
that molecules generated during cell
line selection activities
these molecules include as you can see
maps drug conjugates vaccine and
multi-specific maps used in urine
oncology
cell line development is depicted in
this figure as a funneling process where
the most desirable clone is selected
based on product quality expression
stability and title
cld starts with the transfection of the
expression vector with a gene of
interest into a host cell line usually a
chinese hamster ovarian cell line
single cells are next plated by
isolating clones from pools using
processed known as whips or verified
institute plate seeding
these single cell clones are then
expanded to 96 deep plate screenings
fret bad shake flash screenings and
final amber bioreactor screenings to
finally select the top clone
the entire process
takes six months from transfection to
selecting a manufacturing cell
we use fit for purpose analytical
methods including mass spectrometric
assays for product quality analysis
throughout the screening process as
highlighted in the yellow boxes
recently a new process has been
implemented in cld to reduce timing rise
where the process takes four and a half
months from transfection to clone
selection
in the present paradigm more molecules
per target are transfected with fewer
clone screenings and early development
starts from transfected pools rather
than screen clones
the idea of this new workflow is know
more about the molecules faster and have
backups ready to mitigate development
risk
in order to meet these new
deliverables analytical needs to
innovate in technologies
that can increase speed
we believe that automated solutions and
other methods will reduce bottlenecks in
the process where cld campaigns can move
programs faster faster to ind
this brings
me to the main topic of this talk how do
we accelerate biologics character
characterization
we in cld are taking a multi-pronged
approach with innovation happening both
within the group and outside
these are the areas of interest that i
will share today among these we have
established an automated data analysis
as a platform method while the others
listed here are active research
interests to accelerate biologics
characterization
we have an end-to-end automated data
analysis pipeline developed using
protein matrix bios software
key features of this software includes
data generated from different ms
instruments are automatically subject to
a vendor agnostic bionic search
and these are done on group peptide ms
data
then extensive product various searches
of no modification mock known
modifications as well as wildcard
searches of unknown modifications are
carried out
validation of resource and automatic
export of research
are also possible
finally data aggregation with molecular
information is
is uh
is is
done using gene data biologics
recently we have integrated in the
intact ms analysis workflows with
peptide mapping for joint reporting and
comparison of modifications
here's an example of this approach where
we compare modifications of an intact
antibody after mass deconvolution
with the with the reconstructed spectrum
of modifications estimated from the
peptide map of the same antibody
these profiles show good similarity
we are also interested in improving
sample digestion speeds
micro droplet assisted digestion work
was a johnson collaboration with groups
at the new jersey institute of
technology and stanford university who
are pioneering these methods
conventional digestion methods are time
consuming and not amenable to high
throughput characterization of
biotherapeutics
here we describe a method of generating
micro droplets using a mixing tee where
reactants were mixed prior to
electrospray ionization
all reactants are introduced separately
and allowed to react after electrospray
ionization
these methods enable comprehensive
digestion and reduction of disulfides of
antibodies at an unprecedented speed of
four seconds in the former case to as
fast as 250 milliseconds
per sample in the latin case
ides and pngasf
two of the most widely used enzymes for
antibody digestion in conjunction
with a t-set chemical reduction is
performed via
multiple sequential reactions are in a
single reaction step using these micro
droplets
here's a monoclonal antibody
fab and single chain fc fragments that
are generated by its enzyme and compared
with in solution digestion
the top spectrum shows completed
digestion of the antibody to fab and
single chain fc fragments
in four seconds the bottom spectrum
shows the same intake antibody that
remains
undigested after five minutes of
insulation digestion
considering typically in solution
digestion of a map with ice takes
approximately 30 minutes or longer to
complete
micro drop blood digestion offers a 450x
improvement in speed
we next generate antibody subunits by
reduction and ice digestion
the reaction performed in a t junction
takes place in approximately four
seconds
the deconvoluted mass spectrum shows
like chain fd and the single chain fc
fragments that are each approximately 10
25 kilo dollars
the single chain fc fragments show
characteristic glycans
the same reaction when performed in real
time using two emitters
with the second emitter needle is
nebulizing charged solvent eyes that
react with the neutral antibody
fragments
generate charged fragment eyes
all three antibody fragments are
observed in 250 milliseconds
which is a 7 million x increase in
digestion speeds
ice digestion plays an important role in
the structural characterization of
antibody chains for modifications
the stop spectrum was generated as
before by reduction and ice digestion of
antibodies that were subjected to
glucose stress
the deconvoluted mass spectrum shows
light chain
fd fragments and their mic mono and
diglycated
forms
however we are unable to determine fc
glycation due to the presence of
glycosylation
both glycan and glycosylation masses are
the same
we next perform pngs if fd glycosylation
in micro droplets where 90 percent of
the antibody
antibody gets stripped of their glycans
in four seconds as seen in the
decommulated spectrum at the bottom
finally we combine png sf reactions with
its digestion and reduction to generate
fc fragments free of any glycosylation
we are also interested in improving
sample separation speeds to accelerate
biologics characterization
i will show a couple of case studies on
how we use separations technologies to
speed up characterization
in the first case study we are
investigating clipping on a fc fusion
protein
clipping can take place by non-enzymatic
mechanisms as well as due to the
activity of enzymes present in cell
culture harvest
identification of clip sites are
challenging
and clip sites are important in the
development of safe and efficacious
therapeutics
here's our workflow for clip site
identification we label proteins with
pmpp which is a chemical tag that
professional preferentially reacts with
mostly in terminal of a protein
and then we digest this protein with
trypsin
or any other protease
the digestive digestive peptides that
have the tnpp tag are combined
by detecting of specific report ads upon
ms2
further report ions are used to trigger
additional ms2 scans to confirm the
sequence
using this approach we examine the
diagnostic utility of report ions with
over 1000 tmpp label peptides from a
k562 cell line total cell badges
in addition to the highly selective
nature of these report ions we noted
that most labeling occurs at the
n-terminus and that labor peptides are
significantly hydrophobic compared to
their unlabeled
unlabeled peptide counterparts
therefore these peptides elude during
the rapid sawtooth ramps of plc gradient
as shown here
using this information
we have completely automated the process
for looking at clip size then assaymap
brow system is used for labeling and
digesting steps of this workflow
and rapid lc separation followed by
targeted ms is performed to detect clip
peptides all within 12 minutes
rapid and highly selective separations
are achieved for detecting clipping of
the fc fusion proteins
as well as nist map and terminus and we
can obtain rock curves
with high sensitivity and specificity
for the k-562 label peptides when
retention time of the labor peptide used
as the predictor
as you can see we get a very decent rock
curve with the auct of greater than 99
in the second case study we are using
iron mobility separations performed
using structures for lossless iron
manipulations or slim to speed up
biologics characterization
slim experiments were performed in a
jansen collaboration with mobileiron
systems who is the exclusive licensee of
the sim slim technology for
commercialization purposes
in this workflow shown here we
investigate the release glycans from
human serum rtg of lupus and healthy
subjects
igg from serum is purified and glycans
from purified igg are released and
labeled
these released glycan samples are then
introduced using an agilent lc
by flow injection to a slim device that
is coupled to an agilent 6545 xt mass
spectrometer
the animation shows the operation of
slim eye mobility ms system
we introduce a 30 centimeter long slug
of sample by flow injection
these molecules are ionized by
electrospray into a heated capillary and
focused using an iron funnel
the total sync path is 13 meters long
serpentine path where iron ions can be
accumulated on board and release based
on the collision cross sections
the arrival time for ions are recorded
along with their mass spectra to give us
a two dimensional plot of mobility and
mro z
55 iron packers are collected
within these two minutes of flow
injection runs this gives us roughly 49
packets of data for the 30 seconds of
the flow injection
this is a comparison of helic ms with
slim
ims ms analysis of released glycans
we can see that a typical helicon takes
15 minutes to separate glycans whereas
ims
can separate glycans in less than
seconds of runtime
the table uh
shows that many more glycan species are
detected using
two minutes flow injection run in
comparison to the 15 minutes of electron
times
we detected glycans that have a wide
range of mro z's and drift times if we
zoom into the most
relevant glycans we detect isomeric
glycans for g0f g1f and the scilated g1f
which is g1fs
here is an overall view of the glycan
distributions for both lupus and healthy
subjects
we also have a two global internal
standards from cool glycans for healthy
and lupus samples we collected
which are labeled as control 1 and
control 2.
it is known that galactose levels are
implicated in autoimmune disorders
low galactose levels have been reported
for rheumatoid
arthritis by us and others in previous
studies
however glycans derived from auto
antibodies in our analysis for lupus
does not show a statistically
significant lowering of galactose they
when we examine the intensity ratios
between g1f and g0f that is a measure of
a single galactose or intensity ratios
between g2f and g0f which is a measure
of two galactose units
we next looked at additional isomers
observed by sim separations for example
g1f glycan is resolved into three
reproducible peaks
this was performed in triplicate
measurements for all samples that were
analyzed
we used the intensities of the three g1f
isomeric species as
separately as predictors to categorize
lupus and healthy subjects
to our surprise rock curves are the
third g1f glycan
species is more predictive of the
disease state compared to the first and
second g1f glycan isomers
in the third case study we are using
slim separations to speed up
characterization of antibody drug
conjugates or adcs
an important parameter of evaluating the
conjugation of a small molecule drug to
the antibody is drug to antibody ratio
or da value
traditionally we have obtained r values
using time consuming 2d lcms analysis
here we are using size exclusion
chromatography separation in the first
dimension followed by reverse phase
separation in the second dimension
using multiple hard cutting two
dimensional lcs to obtain data values
by the ms signal
in this analysis we observe that the sec
retention time correlates very well with
the da value
alternative to this we can speed up the
characterization use using slim
slim adx
slim adc experiments were performed in a
johnson collaboration with the pacific
northwest national lab
in this experiment we were able to
rapidly and simultaneously identify
conjugated species as is and estimate
the dal values accurately for both the
heavy and light chains of a model
antibody drug conjugate
these da values were obtained in
significantly less time compared to size
exclusion chromatography
of the intact antibody and we can also
see that the da values compare quite
well with the sccms
multiplexing
multiplex sample analysis is another
important method to increase throughput
in biologics characterization
isobaric labeling reagents such as
standard mass tags or tmt for short and
other reagents have been used widely in
proteomics for relative and absolute
quantification
however their use in pharmaceutical
characterisation is rather limited
here we are using tandem mass tags to
create isobaric label peptides to
estimate the occupancy of a small
molecule drug conjugated to antibody
as shown in the diagram the workflow
starts with labeling the unconjugated
cysteine site of a protein of the adc
sample
and the same antibody without the drug
we call a mock sample
is then labeled with a first pair of
cysteine reactive tnt reagents or iodo
tmts
these parallel samples are then
trypsinized and the resulting peptides
are labeled with a second tmt tag
that are reactive to the n-terminus and
the license of the peptides
the peptides are pooled and then mixed
in equimolar ratios and analyzed by lcms
the peptides when subjected to ms2
generate these tnt report ions as shown
in the spectrum
for both the first and the second pairs
of tmp labels from which the occupancy
of the drag conjugation can be derived
as shown in the equation below
here are a few examples of site-specific
occupancies estimated persisting
conjugate
different sites have different
occupancies as seen in the top panel
the spectra show the reporters and the
bottom panel shows the corresponding
fragment eyes that localize the
conjugation size
once we obtain the occupancies for each
site we make use of the non-system tmp
ratios of the spectra which have
exclusively the second tmp label to
obtain a normalized section
factor between the conjugate and the
mock sample
we then use this factor to correct
occupancy
estimates for each site specific
existing conjugation site
using this approach we can multiplex up
to four different conjugation reactions
to estimate occupancies of a drug in a
single experiment
the experiment shown here is a
site-specific occupancy estimation using
tnt templates reagents to monitor the
conjugation of four different
conjugation reactions in a single run
with unprecedented throughput
our final approach to speed up biologics
characterization is rapid sample
introduction with no separations
this type of analysis is particularly
important for multi-specific antibodies
that can be introduced
to desired heterodimers as well as
undesirable homodynes during single cell
cloning
cell line development activities require
rapid product quality analysis
specifically looking at chain tearing of
multi-specifics
one needs to screen large number of
clones during cell line development
stages to identify and rank order cell
lines with the highest percentage of
these heterodivers
we are using rapid fire ms with cycle
times of 8 to 10 seconds per sample to
speed up this processing of large
volumes of samples
our approach starts with purified cell
culture material and subjecting samples
mostly in 96 well form to rapid fire msn
analysis
the data generated from these
experiments can be split to individual
files
and processed using a intact ms data
analysis pipeline
where intact mass spectra are
deconvoluted and intensities are
reported for each clone for various
species as shown in the heat map at the
bottom
here is an example where only 13 of the
high titer clones moved into cell line
selection due to high levels of
homodimers and half mass detected
through this type of analysis
in addition to chain misspelling we are
also exploring the use of rapid fire ms
for other applications
product quality attributes such as
glycostation can be estimated by
performing rapid fire ms analysis on
antibody fragments
in this example
we investigate the glycans of the heavy
chain located in the father and fc
domains using eyes
we can generate the fb and fc regions of
the antibody and analyze each individual
chain
for their glycan distribution
in addition lycos attenuation on
multi-specifics can be compared
by reduced mass analysis
the non-identical glycans on each heavy
chain can be rapidly analyzed using
rapid fire during product quality
screening
we have compared glycans between lcms
and rapid fire ms approach and find a
good correlation between the major
glycoforms
finally rapid fire ms can be used to
examine maps under native conditions
and here we are using charge reduction
to strip charges on a monoclonal
antibody to increase the distribution of
peaks that we believe
will help to improve charge
deconvolution
in this example we are increasing the
flow of the charge reducing reagent
introduced from the agilent reference
spray every fifth injection during the
rapid fire run
in conclusion i hope you have seen the
variety of methods we have developed to
accelerate biologics characterization in
a stage appropriate manner
these enabling technologies include
increasing digestion speeds several
million fold using micro droplets
as i pointed out micro droplets actually
accelerate otherwise very slow reactions
and is transformative in the
characterization of biologics with
increased throughput and versatility
next we examine short gradient lcs and
ion mobility separations to speed up
analysis time at unprecedented speeds
sample multiplexing for accurate and
fast quantitation was also this was also
demonstrated using tandem mass tag
approaches
and finally rapid sample introduction
from screening to product quality
assessment of molecules was
was demonstrated
uh what is the future our future is
looking bright we are continuously
innovating and improving our analytical
methods
informatics capabilities to become an
industry leader in biologics
characterization
we also see opportunities for
improvement in sample management and
data tracking systems
integrating high throughput mass
spectrometry with robotic sample
preparation
is one of the areas that we are looking
into
also increasing the information context
of our analysis by integrating various
assays
mass spectrometry assays with probably
biophysical assays in an
autonomous fashion so that we can
integrate results and deliver these
results to our stakeholders in an
integrated fashion
we admission technological innovation
will provide time to value in biologics
characterization
with that i would like to thank
all the color all the contributors at
jensen and our research partners and
collaborators finally i would like to
thank you for a participation in this
webinar and happy to answer any
questions thank you
thank you dr genordena for your
informative presentation we've received
some great questions already
our first question is
is micro micro droplet digestion being
performed on chemical reactions
uh it is um so this technique has been
pioneered by groups
both at purdue university and at the
at this at stanford
and both these groups uh professor cooks
and professors there have performed
these types of reactions
uh for organic molecules
and uh this uh
has a huge potential even for
pharmaceuticals biologics where
certain biologics need to be
modified
one such example which i've shown is
antibody drug conjugates and various
types of chemical modifications like
tmpp
and these are some of these uh chemicals
that we can use to
modify the proteins uh antibodies and
antigens
and these are some areas that we are
exploring in the future
okay great thank you i have another
question
is the multiplex experiment
uh in the multiplex experiment what is
the use of the second tmt tag
yeah that's excellent question uh so
this multiplex experiment uh
is a little different to the typical
proteomics experiment where researchers
typically use one type of labeling
reagent either it's a
lysine or
lysine or primary amine reactive
reagents or cysteine reacting reagents
uh it has never been used uh together uh
in a single experiment so the idea
behind this type of design is to use the
second label to do normalization
especially when we are looking into
conjugates in this particular experiment
we are trying to determine occupancy
the two work streams parallel work
streams can
can
needs to be um
the the protein amounts in the two
parallel workflows need to be the same
similar so in order to account for any
um
errors introduced during experiments
such as mixing errors
and
reaction errors we use we have to
correct for for the differences so we do
that by uh using the second reagent
which typically reacts with the
n-terminus or a lysine on the peptide
that we can use to normalize the ratios
and correct for any
errors that were introduced during
sample preparation
okay thank you for that
so far we have one more question
in the clipping experiment
are there any tags you can use for
detecting c-terminus clip sites
yeah excellent question again
so far uh the the the
the reagents that are available um
chemically is to react with the
interminus there's no reagent that can
efficiently tag at the c terminus
however
as i pointed out clipping is pretty
important attribute in biotherapeutics
characterization not all peptides that
we measure during such experiments
create
peptides that are sufficiently long to
be detected only at the end terminus so
there needs to be
age reagents that can also attach to the
c terminus
although there aren't
any reagents that are available
in the market at least for now
the c-terminus there's some research
groups especially in the organ
organic synthetic
organic synthesis where
people are trying to develop uh
c-terminal probes uh
bioconjugation probes by using
photochemical reactions
so these are still research interests as
they're still in research and not
commercially available but that is
something that
we would like to see happen and made
available to the uh by the broader
community balance the community so that
we can use this for biologics
characterization
right well thank you so much as a
reminder to our audience questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed via the email address
you provided at the time of the
registration
thank you again to our speaker harsha
gunawardena phd and to everyone who
participated in this presentation we
hope you enjoy the rest of the event